entry is the S of alpha we can by the way restrict our attention to values of alpha between zero and Pi because any
other value of alpha will give us a vector that's equivalent up to a global phase to one where Alpha is in this
range if we compute the density matrices associated with these states expressed as linear combinations of poly matrices
we get the expression that is shown here on the screen that computation isn't shown here but that is what you should
get if you go through it and what we find is that these states form a so-called great circle that goes
through the poles specifically starting from the North Pole when Alpha is zero going down the prime meridian and
hitting the South Pole when Alpha is pi over 2 and then back to the North Pole on the opposite side of the sphere as Alpha ranges from pi over 2 to
Pi and that all makes sense because number one these are real vectors so the imaginary part is always zero and number
two the angle Alpha effectively gets doubled on the Block sphere and once again that can be explained by the use
of the double angle formulas we've seen that the block sphere provides a very nice geometric representation for the pure states of a
cubit where each point on the sphere corresponds to a unique pure state of a cubit and vice
versa when we refer to the block ball we're talking about all of the points on the Block sphere as well as the points
contained inside of it points on the interior of the block ball also correspond to Cubit States
specifically states that are not pure States so in other words these are Cubit states that can be represented by density matrices but not by Cubit State
vectors a fundamental aspect of the block ball and the way that the interior points represent impure States is that
convex combinations of points inside of the block ball correspond to convex combinations of density matrices
intuitively speaking this means that the geometry continues to work perfectly even inside of the block
ball let's take a look at a couple of examples beginning with the center point of the block ball which represents the
completely mixed state the completely mixed state is obtained by averaging the zero and one states which is consistent with the fact
that the center of the sphere is exactly halfway between the North Pole and the South Pole and in fact it's halfway between any two antipodal points such as
the plus and minus States and the plus I and minus I States antipodal points in the block sphere always correspond to
orthogonal Pure States and what this reveals or reflects is that we can always write the completely mixed state
as the average between any two orthogonal pure Cubit States another way to see this is to
think about the poly Matrix representation of the completely mixed state to make this work we have to set
the coefficients on all all three non-identity poly matrices to be zero and so the corresponding Point inside of
the block ball is right in the center at the origin and by the way thinking about poly Matrix representations of density
matrices like this actually makes it pretty clear that convex combinations of block ball points correspond to convex
combinations of density matrices if we take an average or a weighted average of density matrices and
express everything in terms of linear combinations of poly matrices then of course we're just averaging the corresponding points because everything
is linear in those three coefficients for one more example let's consider the average of the zero State
and the plus state which we saw earlier in the lesson we calculated the density Matrix representation which is shown on the
screen and we have that the point is in the interior of the block ball halfway between the zero and plus
States we also saw that we could express this density Matrix in a different way based on its spectral decomposition and
again that is consistent with the diagram and the previous examples and that concludes the
discussion of the block sphere and block ball people often ask if there's a block sphere or block ball for systems having
three or more classical States and the unfortunate answer is not really we can always think about the
quantum states of a system in geometric terms similar to The Block ball and we'll get a convex body in a real Vector
space but if we have three or more classical States it won't be spherical for instance if we have
exactly three classical States or a q trit for short we'll get a convex body in an eight-dimensional
space but the extreme points of that body which correspond to the pure Quantum states of a CIT will only be
four-dimensional if you can visualize taking a four-dimensional manifold in an eight-dimensional space and somehow shrink wrapping it to obtain a convex
body and you find that to be a helpful way of thinking about cits then more power to you I guess it's interesting to
think about but it's not a ball it's more complicated than that in the final part of the lesson we'll briefly discuss
how density matrices work for multiple systems density matrices can represent states of multiple systems and this
works in a completely analogous way to Quantum State factors in particular just like we have in a simplified formulation of quantum
information we can view multiple systems together as if they're single compound
systems this time both the rows and Columns of density matrices that represent states of multiple systems are
placed in correspondence with the cartisian product of the classical State sets of the individual systems for example we can consider
density Matrix representations of the Four Bell states which we obtain precisely as we did for other Quantum
State vectors earlier in the lesson by multiplying State vectors to their conjugate transposes and the results are shown here on the
screen in essence there's really nothing new at a conceptual level although we will see momentarily that there are some
new things that we can do with density matrices for multiple systems the Notions of Independence and
correlations carry over from Quantum State vectors to density matrices and in particular we find that tensor products
of dens dity matrices represent Independence between systems we use the same terminology that
we did for Quantum State vectors for instance if we have a system X that's prepared in a state row and a system y
That's independently prepared in a state Sigma then the state of the pair XY together is given by the tensor product
of row and sigma we call this a product State and this generalizes in a natural way to more than two
systems density matrices that can't be expressed as product States represent correlations between systems and that
part is similar to Quantum State vectors but as it turns out there are different types of correlations that can arise when we use density matrices even for
just two systems in contrast there's really only one type of correlation we can have for Quantum State vectors and
that's entanglement to say this another way correlation and entanglement are synonymous for Quantum State vectors but